i
y ha pasado una década desde las
revoluciones que sacudieron el sur del
mediterráneo para tratar de poner fin a
las dictaduras consolidadas tras la
colonización revoluciones más conocidas
como primaveras árabes y concretamente
túnez es el país del magreb donde más se
ha conseguido avanzar hacia la
democracia tras derrocar pacíficamente
al dictador a ben alí las mujeres
tuvieron un peso muy importante en las
movilizaciones sociales y también en los
procesos resultantes un peso marcado por
su participación en la acción política y
también por su representación en las
instituciones tanto es así que en las
elecciones locales del año 2018 las
mujeres lograron conseguir hasta un 47
por ciento de los puestos y aunque a día
de hoy en túnez existe el pluralismo
político y se ha avanzado mucho lo
cierto es que la pobreza y la corrupción
siguen a la orden del día y se fueron
desvaneciendo las promesas de la
revolución y muchas mujeres perdieron la
esperanza en conseguir logros políticos
para vivir en un país próspero lo que se
tradujo en una baja participación en las
elecciones legislativas de 2019 donde
solamente participaron el 36% de las
tunecinas
[Música]
las egipcias estuvieron en la primera
línea durante las protestas de la
revolución de enero en tahrir pero han
estado también en los años posteriores
los revolucionarios decían que no había
revolución sin un cambio para las
mujeres sin que hubiera igualdad para
ellas estuvieron reprimidas y se las
acoso porque formaban parte de las
protestas a diario se las ha sometido
antes de virginidad se las ha sometido a
acoso y a violaciones forzosas pero
aquellos días de tajar y dejaron claro
que las mujeres no iban a mantenerse a
un lado en estos años que han seguido a
pesar de la represión se ha dado
muestras de avances se ha conseguido
presionar para que se produjeran algunos
cambios y sobre todo se ha roto el
silencio desde la campaña internacional
que se produjo con el movimiento de las
mujeres egipcias se están hablando mucho
más contra el acoso el 93,9 por ciento
de las egipcias mejor dicho el 99 3 por
ciento de las de las mujeres en egipto
sufren algún tipo de acoso a diario
ellas presionan para que eso cambie para
que la policía que es uno de los
principales cómplices no siga
participando y por eso protestaron a
encajar ir y todavía siguen alzando sus
voces
[Música]
en el líbano no se buscó derrocar a un
dictador militar ya que el poder no se
concentra en un solo hombre sino en los
líderes de 18 sectas que hay en el país
los libaneses salieron a la calle para
exigir el fin del sistema sectario y de
la élite política que ha conducido al
país a la ruina económica el
confesionalismo está en el día a día de
los libaneses y margina a las mujeres
víctimas del sistema patriarcal y
sectario las mujeres se pusieron a la
vanguardia las protestas y desde el
primer día mostraron su valentía
poniéndose como escudos humanos entre
los manifestantes y las fuerzas de
seguridad
las mujeres de diferente clase y de
diferente religión salieron a la calle
en solidaridad a sus compañeros pero
también para exigir sus derechos
derechos a poder casarse de forma civil
oa poder dar la nacionalidad a sus hijos
si su esposo es extranjero pero las
diferentes crisis que hay en el país han
dejado los problemas de la mujer a un
segundo plano
[Música]